the bellman assists the main objective
of Estonia is to develop open and
innovative European economy therefore we
plan to focus on stable growth through
promoting investments and reducing
market disruptions it should be
supported by resilient banking systems
see a tax system which takes into
account modern digital economy we talked
about the creation of the capital
markets unions it is important for
Europe to have simple access to various
funding opportunities in order to
improve the transparency of the tax
system we spoke about mandatory exchange
of information for tax advisers we
agreed on how to continue work with
non-performing loans the main problems
with impels is the fact that so far the
solutions have been sought the national
level but in this issue we need more
collective approach multi-level action
plan would help us make the financial
system stronger and prevent any problems
with non-performing loans in the future
so Europe is on the right track but we
need to accelerate our action this
action plan has four work strands on
supervisory policies on structural and
legal reforms including insolvency and
law enforcement frameworks on fostering
the secondary markets for NPS and a
support for restructuring of the banking
sector finally - formally adopted this
year's country specific recommendations
member states can now focus on reform
design and implementation the European
Commission stands ready to support this
work